there are new developments in special
counsel Robert militia investigation of
Russian meddling in last year's election
they focus on president Trump's removal
of the FBI director Paula Reid is in
Washington outside the US District
Courthouse Paula good morning good
morning CBS News has learned that
Special Counsel Robert Muller has asked
the Justice Department to hand over any
documents related to the firing a former
FBI chief James Comey now the signals
that Muller is moving full steam ahead
with his probe as to whether or not the
President or anyone else obstructed
justice in the firing of James Comey
nikomia was fired on May 9th after
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
told the president that they believed
Comey was not able to effectively lead
the bureau the next day President Trump
told the Russian ambassador in the Oval
Office that commis firing quote relieved
great pressure on him now sources say
Muller has also asked for any documents
related to attorney General Sessions
decision to recuse himself in the Russia
probe these requests suggest that
sessions is increasingly entangled in
the Russia probe over the next few weeks
Mahler is expected to interview top
White House aides including White House
communications director hope Hicks who
will also likely be asked about the
discussions leading up to the decision
to fire James Comey Norah
all right Paula thank you so much